okay so i just got on twitter because i
mean i basically i'm just on my phone
all day long clicking and scrolling and
mostly twirling on tick tock to be
honest with you but i got on twitter and
i
was like what is this emily a bunch of
other tweets started rolling in saying
that i hit 7 million subscribers on
youtube which has been a long time in
the making i feel like i am so shocked i
just really wanted to make a quick
little video and just say thank you guys
so much for subscribing and supporting
this journey it's been long it's been
incredibly tough at times there have
been ups there have been downs there are
some ups that you have seen there are
some downs that you've seen there's been
a lot of things that you haven't seen
behind the scenes
of just survival and i think the past
couple of years has been incredibly
tough for not only me but many many many
other people i'm just so grateful that i
still really enjoy what i'm doing like i
absolutely love making videos i love
creating and i also love consuming other
creators content because it just feels
like it's such a welcoming place for the
most part at least in the circles and
the content that i'm consuming i'm just
so grateful that you guys have sort of
given me that opportunity to just have a
voice and i was thinking back and like
where i grew up kind of like in the
middle of nowhere and when i first
discovered the internet and found other
people like me that liked the things
that i liked and it just opened my eyes
as a child how much this world has to
offer and at the time because i was very
young the internet was still in its
infancy so it has grown exponentially
for better or for worse but the thing
that i love so much is how much
information is out there how you can
learn absolutely anything that you want
online and that is so powerful i think
knowledge and the freedom of knowledge
is so important for me growing up i
struggled a lot in school i just could
not learn the way that other people
learn i still don't have that way of
thinking that a lot of i guess your
normal neurotypical people are able to
comprehend information i can't do that
but with the internet and with different
ways of learning i can figure out what
style i need and i can find something to
adapt the way that i need to learn or to
read or to comprehend information so i'm
just so excited that a lot of you kids
and even adults now we're all in this
world where we can learn anything and
the possibilities are absolutely endless
when people ask me how have i stayed on
youtube for so long because i didn't
quit that's the only answer even over
this past year i haven't been producing
as many videos as i normally do and it's
not really by choice it's just i've been
going through a lot a lot of health
stuff and finally i'm feeling better
again i guess and i feel like one of the
things that people always see online is
everyone sees the perfect things they
see the happy moments you only see the
good things and we don't share those
kind of tough times i love what i do and
i love to be able to tell stories i love
to be able to create i'm just so happy
that i am in a place and it's taking me
a very long time to get to this mindset
to know that sometimes you yourself your
mental health is more important than
either producing a video posting
something on the internet that is the
first thing that you should take into
account because if you're not okay
you're not gonna be okay for your
audience you're not gonna be okay for
your friends you're not gonna be okay
for your family so taking care of
yourself is one of the most important
pieces of advice that i can give you and
whatever that looks like for you you may
not know at this current point in time
but that's something that i think as we
go through life you figure out ways to
adapt to things that you need for you
and i think that's one of the most
important things you can do i guess this
is getting off topic but i kind of
wanted to
give some advice because i have been
doing this for so long and i feel like
i've shared a lot with you guys and for
creators now getting into this space
it's overwhelming it's daunting and it
can be a very detrimental place to your
mental health and i've seen it
unfortunately happen to many of my
friends who have stopped making youtube
videos because it was too much the
biggest thing is creating consistent
content but also knowing yourself and
knowing how far you can push your limits
to when you need to stop you need to
take a break because i've been there
we've all been there but at some point
enough is enough and you have to take
care of yourself so i just wanted to end
this by saying thank you all i mean when
we look back at some of my first videos
please don't uh
we started from the bottom now we're
here it's been a fun journey and i look
forward to making many more memories and
now here's to i was gonna say 10 million
but we have to get to eight and then to
nine and then to ten but don't worry
we'll get there eventually thank you
guys for watching thank you for
subscribing i appreciate you all and i
look forward to seeing you in the next
video bye
[Music]